marine pensez vous êtes
l'administratrice de l'académie du
spectacle équestre de versailles dans
tous les jours comme ça peu d'effets
vous passer comme ça dans ses écuries ça
fait cinq ans voilà j'ai ce plaisir
depuis cinq ans et je ne m'en lasse pas
un gel c'est quand même un dieu etc sont
nés dont les grandes écuries dont 2 015
droit est donc là on a tous les tous les
chevaux qui sont pour la plupart du duo
italien oui le lusitanien crème aux yeux
bleus et le cheval phare de l'académie
on va dire d'une part parce que le
lusitanien
à des capacités en dressage classique et
crème c'est aussi une volonté de
bartabas parce que
voilà en fait d'un clan ils
réfléchissent bien la lumière ils ont
des yeux bleus magnifiques
donc il ya là on est dans les écuries
alors voilà on s'occupe de chou il ya
des écuyers qui passe avec leur show et
combien de cuillé actuellement non à
onze on peut accueillir jusqu'à douze
écuyers
pour qu'ils aient chacun des choix
intéressants à travailler et puis d'un
point de vue aussi budgétaire puisqu'ils
sont tous salariés tout salarié est
alors non seulement c'est la spécificité
on y monte à cheval mais ils sont il
faut aussi de la danse il faut aussi le
tir à l'arc
tout à fait c'est le principe de
l'académie quand bartabas a réfléchi à
son projet il voulait vraiment que les
écuyers qui rendent déjà avec un très
haut niveau équestre et une formation
pluridisciplinaire pour en faire des
artistes alors le spectacle ça s'appelle
la voie de l'écuyer tous les samedis
tous les dimanches et plutôt que d'en
parler je vous propose qu'on voit pas ce
qu'il me formidable bande annonce sur ce
spectacle on la regarde et puis on en
reparle après
oh
le tight équestre ce sentiment que le
travail développe mais ne saurait faire
naître est aussi nécessaire à l'aiguillé
c'est à dire aux cavaliers artistes qui
est indispensable au peintre le
sentiment de colonne au musicien le
sentiment de l'harmonie du ce
il
je
on
c'est donc la bande à dos peut-être la
voie de l'écuyer la mise en scène
comment aussi
une chorégraphie et la plus filmée par
bartabas nous on est sûrs du résultat
vous ça fait cinq ans que je travaille
ici oui quand vous êtes arrivé dans
cette ville
enfin j'y travaillais pas du tout donc
voila moi c'était pour le spectacle
vivant on va dire et que du coup voilà
je suis tombé dans une compagnie où les
principaux acteurs sont les chevaux
ouais voilà l'issue en fait au moment où
bartabas créer les juments de la nuit
sur le bassin de neptune au château
photo je faisais un stage de fin de
reprise d'études à château de versailles
spectacles et la rencontre c'est comme
ça que vous avez exactement vous êtes
arrivé ici alors cette académie du
spectacle équestre l2 ya dix ans et en
2003 c'est quelles étaient les raisons
de cette de la naissance de cette
académie alors on va dire une
conjonction de deux raisons le château
de versailles qui souhaitait redonner
vie à une partie
des écuries et dans leur fonction
d'origine donc meilleur des chevaux et
puis par ailleurs bartabas qui s'est
interrogé beaucoup sur la question de la
transmission et comment ils pouvaient
transmettre et c'est le mot essentiel je
pense à celle de la transmission par ce
que il ya des faits de transfusion
martha masse vers les ai payées mais
décriée entre eux des écus lyon entre
eux devient en plus une sorte de
formation permanente puisque voilà des
candidatures pour devenir pour
travailler à l'académie du spectacle
équestre et août ouvert toute l'année au
fond tout à fait et puis il n'ya pas un
cursus de trois ans guette les écrits ne
sortent avec un diplôme c'est à dire
c'est on a des écuyers qui sont là
depuis dix ans on peut rester a dit
qu'on veut avi voilà l'idée voilà l'idée
de bartabas et on peut c'est une
comparaison un peu avec l'opéra on peut
entrer petit rares
grandir fine avoir une carrière des
toiles et après une carrière de
l'éventuel manque de formateurs
l'automne quand on est plus quand il
n'est plus possible d'être étoiles donc
il ya des aiguilles qui sont là depuis
la naissance exacte de la voilà qui ont
pris des responsabilités qui forment les
nouveaux arrivants et même dans ceux qui
sont arrivés plus récemment mais qui ont
une passion pour une discipline plutôt
qu'une autre il donne les premiers
enseignements sur ces disciplines là qui
sont c est plié il ya d'abord il ya
beaucoup des cuillères oui alors ce
n'est pas un choix c'est voilà c'est
comme ça ça va être le milieu équestre
celui ci faisait énormément en france et
que si nous on imagine que sur des haut
niveau peut être que les hommes sont
plus attirés par la compétition et les
femmes
avec la sensibilité du spectacle mais
voilà on n'a pas de il n'y a pas de
critère
absolu une femme
cdc des gens qui viennent au milieu du
fameux suppose qu'ils étaient très bons
cavaliers quand c'est des très bons
cavaliers après on a des parcours un peu
atypique on a une ingénieur des mines
qui avait une passion du cheval dès le
début mais qui a fait son diplôme des
mines et puis qui s'est dit bah en fait
la passion du cheval est plus fort et
section du boxer c'est un comme ça c'est
un mélange culturel et sociologique
avons assez important il travaille donc
tous les matins
bien plus que tous les matins
non mais en fait il faut travailler il y
d'abord les faire travailler les chevaux
faut travailler les specs pape tout à
fait ben en fait on les journées
commencent relativement tôt et
puis pour le effectivement
essentiellement le travail des chevaux
le matin et les formations artistiques
l'après midi donc qu'est-ce que vous
retenez vous des cinq ans vous avez
passé ici même au four des dix ans
de l'académie du spectacle équestre
qu'est ce que vous avez vu évoluer alors
je dirais que d'une compagnie école où
l'école était particulièrement présente
on est vraiment sur une compagnie avec
de la formation permanente que les
écuyers ont une capacité d'adaptation
pour des créations différentes dans des
lieux atypiques etc qui est assez
exceptionnel et puis on a aussi une
reconnaissance en tant que compagnie de
spectacles équestres
face à celle obtenue au fil du temps
c'est au début voilà ont regardé ça
comme un peu avec des comme quelque
chose expérimentalement saison oui et
que maintenant il ya une vraie assise et
une vraie reconnaissance d'un
corps de ballet à c'est
assez unique à celui qui est très haut
très haut niveau les spectateurs qui
viennent
donc on faisait la voie de l'écuyer
samedi dimanche et aussi des matinées un
peu on peut venir à 6,16 qui est quand
même très intéressant puis on peut aussi
visiter la le lieu où on est c'est à
dire des écuries
les spectateurs c'est qui
ce loyer ou si c'est assez varié c'est
un public relativement familiale
et sensible essentiellement français et
même franciliens voilà notre
implantation juste en face du château ne
fait
pourtant pas forcément dans les jours
qui viennent visiter le château d'assas
que les visites du château sont montrés
chronométré pour l'essentiel est que du
coup
les deux bronzes
voilà alors on y travaille vous non mais
justement alors on est un petit peu le
bal à venir de cette académie du
spectacle équestre c'est quoi les
perspectives pour vous
déjà on se reconcentre sur cette année
des dix ans avec une grosse
manifestation à la grande halle de la
villette puisque on investit la grande
halle au mois de juin prochain pour un
mois avec tous les matins des séances de
travail en libre accès pour le public
treize représentations de notre dernière
création qui était un projet
co écrit par carolyn carlson oui avec un
ring bartabas et donc avait fait rentrer
des gens qui sont pas du milieu du
spectacle ce qui leur donne une
profondeur une esthétique extraordinaire
voilà on reprend ce spectacle donc seize
danseurs nos cavaliers
et puis pour finir notre présence là-bas
bar tabac se fera d improvisation avec
des invités différent chaque soir
d'accord voilà
deux ans vous avez du boulot mais con
quand vous imaginez un peu des deux les
années à venir quelles sont les
évolutions vous souhaiteriez voir venir
alors je pense que les écuyers et bar
tabac sont prêts à justement a multiplié
les collaborations avec d'autres
artistes
voilà je crois que ça va être ça dans
nos projets d'essayer voilà de mélanger
comme vous nous dites différents champs
artistiques
pour les lier aux spectacles caisse
jusqu'au bal de bartabas pour conclure
qu'est ce qui vous a apporté vous la
passion
voilà c'est quelqu'un qui vit à 200
voire même traçant à leurs noms mais
voilà il ya brillant mais
son projet les chevaux c'est sa vie
et du coup en même temps il a des idées
il a plein d'idées tout le temps et du
coup voilà c'est fait on est beau c'est
bien difficile à la rixe il est chaud
c'est un peu votre vie aussi maintenant
à la wii a choisi je vous garde encore
quelques retiennent distance je soigne
on voit pas dans le spectacle photo non
non non il ya peu de chance qu'on me
voit déjà si on me voit sur un cheval
ils ont fait de la montée maintenant
j'ai une non non ah bon vous avez peur
des chevaux j'ai eu des experts et je
suis monté petit et ça n'a plus en mains
je préfère en rester là bas c'est bien
autour de résilience merci infiniment
marine pour 7 mai de rien à très bientôt